in the little town of kondal in the
middle of the wine growing region of Gus
kanya everything seems totally ordinary
but this man is proof that it isn't
marijuana been Hamed is under house
arrest and is not allowed to leave the
town I have to report to the police at
nine fifteen in the morning noon three
in the afternoon and 6 15 in the evening
in the past one and a half years I must
have walked a total of at least four
thousand kilometers through the town
many more meaning the walks to the
police station are now part of his
routine Marilyn been Hamid was convicted
of planning an attack on the Russian
embassy in Paris and spent almost a
decade in prison after he served his
sentence France wanted to deport the
father of three to Algeria but the
European Court of Human Rights wouldn't
allow that to happen Ben Hamid faces the
death penalty in Algeria so he remains
in France with his wife and their
children well oh come over our three
children were born in France but they're
unable to assert their rights in my case
that's normal I'm an Algerian but my
children that's something different solo
of course knew of course the French
government once been harbored to leave
and find a country that will accept him
the family doesn't get any financial
support from the state huzzle kezule
we've been suffering for 13 years my
children and I being punished in the
place of others Julian don't do leaping
in every other European country people
feel compassion for the prisoners at
Guantanamo she bugs yourself but it is a
pity poor little no one feels sorry for
us more than not yeah so yeah
the community didn't accept the Islamist
willingly the decision was made by the
French interior ministry but it's
refusing to comment the town hall and
prefecture are also keeping quiet public
officials in the small town aren't
telling the citizens anything she won't
quit at all I don't know why he's living
here most people will say the same thing
we don't know why he's here or what he's
done because he figures he'll offer but
I don't think it's good these people
have to be closely monitored at the show
he took the people pen Hamid denies
having planned terrorist activities in
France he's also not commenting on any
attacks by Islamist extremists elsewhere
in the world the shorts cuz you've got
for moi what am I supposed to say about
the attacks of September 11 or about bin
Laden you can talk about those things
forever what do you think about bin
Laden or Barack Obama that just goes too
far terrorism expert Jean Shabri Saar
has often her dancers like this he
doubts whether the authorities are
cracking down hard enough he says ben
hamid could communicate with extremists
using his home computer supposedly
problemo come too secretive asteroid to
meet you too much the man presents a
serious security threat what duties
offer me the house arrest is problematic
it on youngleafs aug there have been
several other people in the same
situation who have planned new attacks
pehle non possiamo teka teka part of a
CCTV and that's precisely the dilemma
facing the french government there's not
enough evidence to send Mohamed back to
prison but Judge version you do vows
says that France can't simply deport him
without another country's agreement to
accept him so France has exhausted its
legal options loch skeen yahoo not
Aleksandr Davydov Jose ago when people
are deported they usually sent back to
their home countries Sonny a whole year
explicit nope general more about Sonia
widows will be so when that isn't
possible
the prefecture can order this person to
be placed under house arrest you prefer
loop it loop i fed boo pornoid wanna
bail unison Yeshua ha sedo's been
hamed's lawyer says the house arrest was
simply an excuse to continue to monitor
him she wants to take legal steps to
ensure he'll be able to leave France
without the written approval of another
country Ellie Anthony du territoire the
restrictions on Penn hamed's movements
only apply within France Asian wapa
achates lit up otherwise the law says he
may go wherever he wants muwah envenomed
kid so I don't understand why the French
interior ministry is threatening him
with prison if he should try to leave
France I'll and so absurd one that I
can't stay here well but he can't leave
France either let alone valve in the LD
30-12 but only until did k telephones
it's 530 in marijuana bin hamad is on
his way to the police station he's asked
for permission to live in 18 countries
so far Daniel dome on the simulated i
sent my last request to portugal they
said i had to be in the country already
before i could submit a request for
asylum all you want but France won't let
me leave the whistle it's a catch-22 who
knows for how long just call Congress
with all another Islamist sentenced to
house arrest recently fled the country
and when the cameras turned off
marijuana been Hamid admits to us he's
toyed with the idea of doing the same